so can bodybuilders fight that's a topic
that I wasn't gonna touch but then I did
yeah I wasn't gonna do this video but
then I saw quite a few others where
people were espousing some rather
opinionated opinions and I just wanted
to throw my hat into the ring so like
these videos are coming from the same
place that people saying a body bill
that could never stand a chance against
a fighter a trained martial artist if
anything they're gonna be slow and
cumbersome and the muscle will just
weigh them down so I'm not here to argue
that a bodybuilder could beat a trained
fighter that's certainly not true
ultimately a trained martial artist
knows how to use the opponent's energy
against them so that if a punch comes
their way they can block it while
stepping to the side and actually throw
the enemy off-balance so it doesn't
matter how strong you are if they have
superior technique they're going to be
able to deal with your attacks likewise
the trained fighter has got a far better
muscle memory when it comes to
delivering punches and kicks they're
better at balancing they know more
techniques so it is certainly true that
a fighter will beat a bodybuilder so
yeah the bodybuilder isn't going to beat
the fighter in a fight but likewise the
fighter isn't gonna beat a bodybuilder
when it comes to lifting heavy weights
my issue is with the way that body rules
are portrayed in these videos as these
lumbering idiots with all this useless
muscle that isn't going to give them any
advantage in a fight which is just
untrue a lot of these videos start off
by saying how bodybuilders swagger
around the gym looking down on people
like they're better and actually their
muscle is just useless and I kind of
feel like these people are projecting
their insecurities onto these guys
because most bodybuilders I know a you
have no interest in beating people up
they're not training to beat people up
and they don't actually care what you
think most bodybuilders I know are
actually you know so into their sport
into their training and if they're good
at it then they get their confidence
from that they're perfectly happy with
themselves they've got no reason to
prove themselves to you and actually
they're particularly chill guys in my
opinion for that reason most of the time
of course everybody's different you get
[ __ ] bodybuilders just like you get
[ __ ] anybody else and then because
people
feel may be threatened by bodybuilders
because they're bigger or perhaps just
because they've got some idea of
bodybuilders from other videos etc they
start spouting all this nonsense about
body was having fake muscle or useless
muscle and there is some reason to
believe this it doesn't come out of thin
air basically a bodybuilders training
regime is not built around maximal
contraction it's not built around pure
strength that's what a power lifter does
a body builder builds size on the
muscles esthetic muscle the idea is to
look good whether or not you think it
looks good that's entirely your opinion
I personally think it does that's why
superheroes look that way that's why you
know classic greco-roman sculptures look
that way but whatever you think of that
the point is that bodybuilders are
training primarily to look good to look
big or you know in some cases too big
modern bodybuilding that's a whole other
issue point is they're not building
purely strength they're building size
and to build size as a bodybuilder you
train for higher rep ranges using a
slightly lighter weight so you might use
70% of your 1 rep max and then lift it
1215 times as opposed to a power lifter
he'll use 90 to 100% of the warm-up max
and then they'll train with just 1 to 3
repetitions they're trying to utilize
all their strength and one go whereas
the bodybuilder wants to build up blood
in the muscle they want to create lots
of micro tears they want to create
metabolites building up in the muscle
all of which are stimulus is that
trigger growth and hypertrophy so when
you power left and you left a very heavy
weight you're increasing your mind and
muscle connection you're increasing your
muscle fiber recruitment you're causing
micro tears and causing your muscle
fiber to come back thicker and stronger
but in bodybuilding when you train for
higher rep ranges what you're primarily
doing is building up metabolites pooling
the blood inside the muscle this is what
creates that burn sensation and this is
a stimulus of a different kind of growth
which some people refer to as
sarcoplasmic hypertrophy and this builds
the sarcoplasm the muscular equivalent
of cytoplasm in the cells which is a
kind of fluid the stuff floats around it
so this is why people think that power
lifters build a lot more strength than
body builders and it's certainly true
because simply put a power lifter lifts
a heavier weight than a bodybuilder on a
more frequent basis and so body builders
are bill
a slightly different kind of strength
not quite the same amount of explosive
strength but don't get it twisted
because a bodybuilder is still training
with very heavy weights on a very
regular basis they're still massively
increasing their mind to muscle
connection they're still massively
increasing their muscle fiber
recruitment they're building starting
strength explosive strength they are
creating more fast twitch muscle fiber
they're improving their technique when
it comes to lifting simply put a few
lift weights five times a week an hour
at a time you're gonna be stronger it
doesn't matter whether you're doing
bodybuilding or whether you're doing
powerlifting you're gonna be stronger at
one point Franco Columbu was thought to
be the strongest man alive he used
classic bodybuilding techniques you
might think the body will have fake
muscle but I challenge you to go up to a
huge bodybuilder in the gym and charge
him to an arm wrestle and see how you
fare he'll probably do just fine
thanks very much yeah so the power
lifter would have greater strength for a
single exertion than the bodybuilder for
what the bodybuilder is building is
muscular endurance this is the said
principle I've talked about it before
it's specific adaptations to impose
demands if you want to get better at
something you train using that thing so
the bodybuilder trains using longer rep
ranges they exert strength they have a
longer period of time and so they become
better at doing that whereas the power
lifter exerts a lot of force in one go
so they become better at doing that
the power lifter can lift a heavier 1
rep max but the bodybuilder can pump out
more repetitions of 70% of their 1 rep
max that's not non-functional there's no
such thing as non-functional muscle or
non functional strength why would your
body have an adaptation that was purely
for show you wouldn't get to bigger
muscles if it was useless and muscular
endurance is certainly not useless in
fact in the real world what do you have
to do more often you have to lift your 1
rep max when was the last time you did
that or do you have to lift something
very heavy repeatedly say you're moving
home normally you're gonna be lifting
lots of heavy boxes or say you're
carrying a shopping home from the shops
because where else you get shopping
you're going to be using muscular
endurance and in a fight muscular
endurance will help you to hold a
grappling hold for longer it'll help you
to throw punches without losing strength
this isn't about
avascular Fitness is about the power and
your muscles that won't fatigue as
quickly so your punches will be more
powerful for longer if you use
bodybuilding style training and I just
want to address one other fallacy that
I've heard recently in these kinds of
videos which is that bodybuilders have
more muscle and therefore they have more
lactic acid well that's not true and at
the same time lactic acid isn't even
what causes your muscles to burn that
would be lactate and more specifically
the increased acidity caused by the
hydrogen ions and you can increase your
lactate threshold through certain types
of cardio training and it has nothing to
do with muscle size so you're not going
to have more muscle burn because you've
got bigger muscles as I've said in fact
quite the opposite is true if you use
bodybuilding style training you'll have
more muscular endurance
so yeah the trained martial artists will
be either the body builder or the power
lifter when it comes to fighting but
both of them will have a much better
chance in that ring than just your
regular Joe on the street another
criticism people use against
bodybuilders is that they use isolation
training that means curling or it means
any kind of single joint exercise rather
than using your whole body as a
functional unit whereas a power lifter
for instance would use deadlifts or
overhead presses or squats or
what-have-you
so he's using all of his body as one
unit and that's more similar to how you
use your body in real life it's more
similar to grappling for instance in the
ring however this is a myth because
bodybuilders might also use isolation
training but on top of that they also
use compound movements I don't know
anybody bother who doesn't do some
squats some bench presses some overhead
presses some deadlifts you know they use
this stuff too and not only that but
training with isolation movements still
has some translatable crossover when it
comes to performance in the ring I did a
whole video on it so check that out if
you're interested
so yeah bodybuilding is not useless when
it comes to fighting it's in fact very
advantageous when it comes to fighting
as for it slowing you down
that's also a myth any form of
weightlifting will increase your fast
twitch muscle fibers which will increase
you increase your explosiveness certain
forms of training can reduce the lack of
flexible
that can come from lifting weights for
instance using eccentrics will improve
your flexibility as you build the muscle
and there are plenty of examples of very
built guys who have fast powerful
punches and great flexibility and unless
you're a very highly trained martial
artist chances are that someone who's
stronger than you is going to beat you
in a fight
it's like I saw in the comments on
another video I watched on this topic
someone said it's like fighting a
silverback gorilla they might not have
much by way of technique or training but
they're still mighty strong and most
people wouldn't stand a chance and don't
think like every martial artist is
automatically gonna be able to kick ass
either in fact I say a poorly trained
martial artist isn't gonna stand much of
a chance against a very strong
bodybuilder either a lot of people who
went to the martial arts classes I went
to in myself included weren't exactly
you know Bruce Lee and a lot of them
wouldn't stand a chance against on was
just a lot stronger than them and in
fact the most important factor when it
comes to a fight is really the mental
factor it's the willingness to hurt the
opponent and the disregard for your own
safety just that kind of feral instinct
in a street fight someone who has a lot
of experience who isn't scared is gonna
beat someone who is tactically sound but
[ __ ] themselves so really the ideal
fighter is somebody who's highly trained
in martial arts who has chosen the
martial art that suits their body type
and maybe has a background in some
different martial arts somebody who has
real fighting experience on the street
or in the ring as a mixed martial artist
or a cage fighter somebody who is very
strong in terms of their starting and
explosive strength in terms of their raw
power but also has high muscular
endurance and of course they also need
cardiovascular fitness in order to keep
bouncing around moving around the ring
for a long fight I think most street
fights end very quickly but if you're
talking about fights in a ring of any
sort there yeah you definitely need that
cardiovascular endurance too and that's
something that Bruce Lee preached a lot
and sidenote you do get some
cardiovascular benefit from bodybuilding
and I've talked on this channel before
about different ways you can add
cardiovascular training on top of a
regular resistance training workout so
my point is not to say that any form of
training is better than the other in
fact that's really not my point I'm
definitely
saying that a train fight will be a
bodybuilder and a power lifter will lift
heavier weights in the bodybuilder but
the bodybuilder has his own advantages
not only does he look aesthetic but or
she they can lift weights for longer and
that's also useful and I just don't like
this kind of tribe mentality when people
are like this is the best way to train
every other way sucks and they get kind
of really defensive whenever they see a
different training modality I see this a
lot with CrossFit CrossFit's not perfect
no training modality is but you can't
tell me that someone like this Matt
Fraser or rich Froning and not fit guys
people like Earl but they're not proper
pull-ups they're kipping pull-ups and
they're gonna injure themselves or
whatever well fine but you try and do
100 pull-ups of any sort and then tell
me that those guys aren't fit and then
climb up a rope and then ding overhead
presses whatever you think of it those
guys are strong and fit there's no
denying it so instead of saying what's
this new training program I don't like
it instead say what can I learn from
this instead of you know committing
yourself wholeheartedly to one form of
training why not look at all of them and
take the bits you like again we're
getting into a Bruce Lee philosophy here
just you know adopt all the bits that
appeal to you and ignore the rest and
don't just throw the baby out with the
bathwater because you think well I don't
like bodybuilders or CrossFit is
dangerous or I don't like the
organization you know all of these
training modalities have something to
offer and the greatest athlete is
someone who trains in cross my
Daugherty's as much as possible there is
always some trade-off but as much as
possible in order to get the best
physical capabilities across the board
and I don't really have a horse in this
race I wouldn't necessarily consider
myself to be a bodybuilder as such doing
if I'm big enough to be a bodybuilder
and whilst I use some bodybuilding
techniques I really like the way the
principles as I talked about recently I
also like techniques from other training
modalities like CrossFit like
calisthenics like power building like
powerlifting like martial arts and doing
other stuff that I just made up so yeah
that's how I train I'm not saying you
should train that way either I'm just
saying let's all be friends and
bodybuilders have feelings too
so I hope you found this video useful
and interesting guys
if you did then please like please
comment down below feel free to disagree
with me let me know what I bodybuilders
suck or why CrossFit sucks or why
powerlifting sucks away fighters suck or
why MMA sucks or why it's all brilliant
and you think we should all get along
and join hands you'd like to see more
like this then please subscribe hit the
bell button if you want notifications
and stay tuned for many more videos on a
whole range of subjects including
fitness bodybuilding psychology brain
training productivity technology
nootropics you name it if that sounds
good then I'll see you next time thanks
a ton for watching and bye for now